it was fascinating to coincidence this
week but just after at Donald Trump was
decrying the sad changes the immigration
has brought to Europe the descendants of
immigrants were showing just how
dependent nations like France Belgium
and yes England are on their
contribution it's an inconvenient fact
that 15 members of the World cup-winning
French team are of African heritage so
are half of the Belgian team while 11
members of the England side are black or
mixed-race it's obvious that immigrants
have not weakened European culture they
have improved it and I'm happy to see
breaks tears like Michael Gove now
expressing regret for the way the leave
campaign could be seen as having smoked
racially loaded fears about immigration
during the referendum but the reality is
France while enjoying the glory that
immigrants bring has for years been
treating them like crap and so have we
it's time to accept immigration is not a
dirty word it has enriched us all and we
all benefit from it so if we say that
brexit if we kind of agree that brexit
has divided people a lot I would say
that the world cough has significantly
reunited us and I watched every England
game in the pub obviously and I took
great joy in seeing everybody came
together everybody it didn't matter
their race their religion their age the
color of their skin nothing mattered
everybody had this common purpose
everyone was United not just cool
everybody everybody seemed happy and I
thoroughly enjoyed that I really did and
there is a graphic which will pop on the
screen now that would show you what the
English team would look like it wasn't
for immigration and I find that really
powerful and I know that yeah it would
be down to five without immigration so I
do think that we've got an opportunity
to capitalize upon the positive sense of
being United at the moment and I would
like to see I don't know how we do but I
would like to see that bold and take
forward and of course I know that there
are some people that are racist and
stupid and I know that you're gonna
bring in something that shocked me to
the core to think that there's people in
fact should we go to that well we can if
you want to if you finished your own
yeah because I wanna yeah yeah I mean I
think I think just to pick up on that
and just give a bit of context I think
that you're right in what you said that
it it has great potential to unite
people I worry for two reasons one is
1998 France already won under zinedine
zidane of Algerian descent French born
and yet the problems in France weren't
addressed they continued unabated
segregation and discrimination in France
I think is probably worse than here and
I think actually in all of Europe
Britain's probably the better place to
be yet even here people are feeling
increasingly emboldened to speak like
this and this is actually very
interesting as this is the one week I
wasn't on my show and Kevin study and
this is how we had to deal with I
totally disapprove of the multiracial
society the England Football team
doesn't represent me at all in fact it
represents everything that I'm against
I'm sorry you're missing out and being
such a stick-in-the-mud Dean we're we're
a migrant country the French Huguenot
German tribes Irish you're quite right
they were all white people that your
issues you're talking about your that's
your issue do you want England to lose
today yes what because you're so
obsessed by race and your bigotry and
your prejudice is so poisonous you want
England to lose I hate to see my country
destroyed by multiracialism so I've had
people
I was asked would he have said that if
it if you were on a hare and it was
because it's my show and would he have
said that to me directly I have had
people say that to me on air sweetly on
an unabashed unembarrassed of their
bigotry and so just to conclude I think
yeah that there are people that feel
emboldened we do need to definitely
capitalise on this and turn it into
something it France failed to do that
you know how because that second thing I
just very quickly the last point I say
is there is a danger that it's just
reflected in
sport I also want to see that kind of
diversity across all sectors and
increasingly so that we are getting
there in Britain but there is a danger
if it's only in sport that of course it
reinforces also certain stereotypes I
think and just before reading the others
in you know I agree with you Michelle I
think that it is sports ports what we
agree on this and it's good to hear you
as well kind of talking about how
unifying that moment is because that's
what sport can do and I agree with Majid
as well that this is useful if you can
capitalize on it to change perceptions
and for me what I would like to see is
this cognitive dissonance between us
embracing for example the contribution
that people black people and mixed-race
British people are making to football
with wider attitudes so one quarter of
British people currently admits to being
racist this is people self-defining in a
poll last year and there's you know the
loads of evidence we've had
conversations show before that we have
these problems in France macron has just
decided to abolish race from the
Constitution that might sound like a
progressive move but what it does is
mean you can no longer measure the
impact of race discrimination because
you're denying that it exists as a
concept when France has terrible
problems with racism in discriminations
so for me the way to move forward is to
take this and say how can we actually be
honest about the problems we have in
science has always told not regards
decision was that he refused to
reconsider the policy they've always had
it's always been if you go back I mean
there's an interesting quote from
jean-marie Le Pen back in 96 when he
said after France had been knocked out
the euro as I said it's artificial to
bring foreign players here and baptize
them the thing and baptize the French
team though I could think of other names
for them they put an Algerian in to
please the Arabs a Kanak who can't even
sing the national anthem blacks to
satisfy the Antilles none of them has
any place in a French team now if you
then looked what happened in the songs
Alesha on Sunday night you'd have
thought figure you know now I grew you
know it was such a massive celebration
now I agree with you whether that has a
long-term impact on France I don't know
I don't know I've always thought the
Frances more races Society than what the
film it's it's a great film that depicts
a lot of life in the suburbs in France
and Paris is a lot more segregated than
in race just play some of your words
back to you for a company whether it is
immigration or immigrants were being
treated as as dirty work look
immigration immigration as a dirty word
just expand on that what we've seen if
you do Windrush come on we all know less
so I remember with then I don't know the
last 5-10 years immigration being
accepted as a problem per se being
something that only the right said so
now it being all the mainstream others
with the exception of Liberal Democrats
saying that immigration is a proper done
and controlled immigration is a problem
right but nobody advocates on control so
it has to be controlled you see what
we've seen is going from talking about
policies about immigration how people
who are perceived as being defensive
immigration are treated in this country
your introduction to our conversation
should have had the word uncontrolled in
front of immigration because immigration
isn't a dirty word uncontrolled
immigration that's my whole point
people don't discriminate or distinguish
they treat immigration as a problem and
they treat people who look visibly like
they're descended from immigrants as a
problem but listen they're not
distinguishing the figures we came up
with just now you know was twenty five
percent of people identified themselves
as racist that means 75% don't leave me
that's me 75 percent oh no I don't I
don't think that's where we were 20 or
juicy I think sport has changed this
because I think I mean I remember going
to Chelsea in the days when they used to
boo black players and suddenly they
realize that their best players Romelu
Lukaku who's a Belgian striker and he
said this and this reminds me something
that happened in Britain as well
he said when things were going well so
he's talking about for him I was reading
newspaper articles and they were calling
me Romelu Lukaku
the Belgian striker when things weren't
going well they were calling me Romelu
Lukaku
the Belgian striker of Congolese descent
if you don't like the way I play that's
fine but I was born here I'm Belgian and
you know what that reminds me of my
Farrah who's our great British hero as
soon as there was a controversy about
his coach he suddenly became Somali born
Mo Farah we do that it's in our
subconscious
of all the English players know exactly
that's what I mean I don't think you
should I don't anyone knows none of them
are x-rays which I mean you know the
largest growing minority group in
Britain no I think my knowledge includes
mixed-race a lot of them a mix right
yeah I don't I have no I don't know
which things they play for I read a
study about Jessica Ennis and Mo Farah
right they both have african heritage
right Rodan just enos's father is of
Jamaican yeah so it was really
interesting that when Jess Ennis is
described in the press she's always
talked about as Sheffield
Sheffield yeah which makes her sound
very English and kind of my ferret has
always talked about as of Somali
heritage even though he's always British
and the way these perceptions about
immigrants being something that is bad
the reaction to the Windrush scandal was
heartening though because yes he
everyone was agreed
like shut jab you played a blinder there
is hope
I want to say that when I was I think
lightly older than you I think of when I
was young we would have to leave games
15 minutes before the final whistle
because we would be beaten up if by Odin
fans if we were yeah because so so basic
team was done mainly these London teams
right to your West less times Millwall
I grew up in Essex and it was a terrible
thing that not only live in Essex is a
terrible see this is I'm talking before
the murder of Stephen Lawrence right no
person of color would want to be seen in
the stadium 15 minutes prior to the
final whistle a lot of that has changed
and it's important to acknowledge that
in the game but also in the country
because then of course when we
acknowledge where progress has been made
and I think it's but perhaps it is
befitting to say that Britain is still
out of all of the European countries the
best place to be for people of color and
it is it genuinely is but then of course
there's a lot more to do as well but I
think it is important to acknowledge
where progress is made because then
people take us seriously when we point
to things that do need to be improved
but they're not where I just said to you
when we said three-quarters of people
we're not racist I said don't you know
that's a good thing and you said no to
me is a really good thing at a signal
I think we spend a lot of time self
congratulating in fact when I wrote on
my books on this topic and something I
was told you were in the book I was told
but one reason right it's because I
didn't spend enough time praising
Britain for how far we come from the
days and people got beaten up every day
because of the father but the skin now
look we have progressed I haven't
experienced the world in which I get
beaten up because I'm black and that's
good but I don't feel like celebrating
that when there are still people being
deported because of their skin colour
when a quarter of people still self
defined as races when one-third of
people of black heritage experience
termination what why why should we all
stop and celebrate that if you're the
person who's experiencing it the fact
that 75 percent of people don't well it
doesn't help